et à 30 ans coup drame après la vitesse
la force que vous mettez on s'en fiche
ce que je sais que vous soyez ensemble
florine emilie et isabelle n'ont qu'un
objectif s'éclater en se dépassant leur
des filles 1re est de 10 jours au sri
lanka
au programme canoë vtt et course à pied
leur préparation depuis septembre
dernier deux heures de course ou de
canaux et tous les soirs et deux séances
intenses de crossfit par semaine là on
va essayer de travailler la résistance
aujourd'hui sur des travaille sur une
minute et
l'entr'aide ce qui va être super
important je pense pour elle il ya
plusieurs qualités dans l'équipe y en a
qui vont être plus endurante d'autres
qui vont être plus fortes
donc maintenant de plus agiles certaines
sont à l'aise en vélo donc moi mais va
falloir qu'ils réussissent à aller
jusqu'au bout avec 15 secondes
on nous a dit que c'était abordable pour
tout le monde donc on se dit avec un peu
d'entraînement on y arriverait bien et
puis plus le temps est passé et puis on
s'est dit il faut quand même s'entraîner
un peu et du coup depuis septembre on
s'entraîne et puis depuis un deux mois à
peu près trois mois on est un peu plus
intense allez allez allez 5 secondes
les solides serrés abdou aux fesses
aller 3-2 le sourire dans l'effort
l'humour pour tenir ces femmes sont
motivées par un objectif collecter dix
mille euros pour thelma le fonds de
dotation pour le handisport né dans le
loir et cher notre vecteur de
dépassement de soi c'est le sport est
des privilégiés on trouve dommage que
des personnes en situation de handicap à
cause du coût du matériel du manque de
structures puissent pas bénéficier aussi
de de ce facteur de développement et de
connaissance et donc on a choisi de
porter les couleurs de telma plus que
deux mois de préparation avant le grand
saut ce sera le 10 octobre au sri lanka
des paysages sublimes et un défi fou les
attendent pour ce raid solidaire
exclusivement féminin